welcome back to CBS this morning I'm
Gayle King with Anthony Mason and Tony
to copal there is a new twist in the
cross country investigation of a bizarre
series of events today an Idaho mother
is being ordered to physically produce
her missing children seven year old JJ
valo and 17 year old Ty Lee Ryan have
not been seen in four months their
mother Laurie valo and her new husband
Chad de Bell were also at the center of
an investigation to the deaths of their
former spouses police found the couple
in Hawaii last week where they tried to
dodge reporters Niki batiste is here
with more on this story Nikki this is so
bizarre I've been following this since
it came to the public light when did the
investigators first become suspicious of
these two good morning Gail well the
events suspicious for a while at a
November welfare check at Val O's home
two months after the children or last
seen
police say lori valo lied to them about
their whereabouts
a day later she and her new husband
disappeared a police showed up to serve
a search warrant why don't you give us
answers Lori Val oh and Chad de Belle
refused to answer his questions
moments after police in Hawaii executed
a search warrant and seized their rented
SUV you had nothing to say valo was
ordered to present the children to Idaho
authorities by today her adopted son
JJ's grandparents Larry and Kay Woodcock
arrived in Idaho Falls last night
bringing the kids that's it Graham
that's all we need to know I don't care
to I scurry along I don't care show me
they're alive that's it I begged the DEA
the FBI everybody that's involved in
this please help us find JJ help us find
Ty Lee I can't ask more I can't beg more
relatives say valo met day Belle before
she was divorced
Charles valo filed for divorce in
February 20 19 confirmed not only about
his wife's radical behavior but also
about seven year old JJ safety he said
his wife made claims she was working to
carry out Christ's Second Coming and
that if he got in her way
she wouldn't murder him just five months
later Charles Bala was shot and killed
by
Lori's brother Alex Cox who claimed
self-defense you came at me with a bat
this body camera video shows Chandler
Arizona police interviewing Cox right
after the shooting three months later in
October chad de belles wife Tammy
mysteriously died in Idaho he married
Val Oh
about two weeks later then in December
Alix Cox also died of unknown causes
there's the multiple deaths with strange
circumstances involving all of them the
missing kids
that's probably part the Woodcock's who
are close with JJ just wanted to know
the children are safe the only thing I
care about is those two grandkids we're
here I'll get on my knees and I'll beg
just give me JJ that's all I want
sheriff Humphreys told us an autopsy was
never performed on Chad de belles former
wife Tammy so her body was recently
exhumed those autopsy results have been
sent to the lab for further testing we
reached out to an attorney for Lauri and
Chad but we have not heard back
a trail of suspicious kids are okay yeah
parents going to the police for help
finding kids now you have the police
going to parents saying where are your
children and they have to do it today
they're supposed to produce them today
yes they have to produce them today and
if not Lori and her new husband will
likely be arrested listen to the
grandfathers how heartbreaking to hear
him say I'd get down on my knees just
bring this little boy back let's hope
the kids pop up all right Nikki thank
you very much